e aí ela ainda assiste meu alongando
tudo bem com vocês é uma coisa que eu
faço muito é falar com as pessoas do
twitter porque o facebook é muito muito
alto não sei quanto meus leitores que
fazem a parada que não me sai direto
direto e foi o twitter não jamais
então 1 e segue no twitter aqui e é isso
aí eu pedi o pessoal do twitter mandar
perguntas para poder responder aqui
vamos às perguntas agora já tocava agora
já vamos às perguntas
agora manda primeiro dia são tudo bom
e aí não caio joseph é o seguinte wilson
porque é esse nome não vendo sem ofensas
tinha que começar com essa eu acho
engraçado a galera fala como se fosse o
dia escolhido o nome acaba de nascer
foi como é e foi pressionando inem leva
eu fiquei pelado no lado ninguém na
minha próxima pergunta da vitória vieira
se você acredita em amor à distância
errou a primeira vista essa pergunta
você acha que o céu porque seu saque e
viu a distância ou à primeira vista e
mandou beijos pra mim com certeza não
ver com você eu acredito em amor à
distância
também
acredito em amor à primeira vista à
segunda vista terceiro vídeo pra mim
tanto valem eu sou um cara que bota fé
do bota fé no amor também evitar que
essa rapariga ela ficou com medo que tem
o do futebol só não existe amor primeiro
nome né
quando ela com isso aí eu falo nem vai
embora
eu aprecio amor à distância a uma
primeira vista foi nós não tem vindo a
próxima pergunta que rodrigo lopes
porque as meninas é claro que estão sem
namorar ser que você está fazendo de
tudo pra seu namorado dela era só um
time e falassem melhor hidratante ou não
mas é assim quando a minha equipe
fazendo charminho e e em guiné anauê a
nrg da cabana vez de gay é botar no
facebook estão estou completando um ano
de namoro hoje se tivesse começando
amanhã atrás sem pra mim é besteira é
maneira essas coisinhas que é melhor
para mim é melhor parar para tomar
exaltada pelo próxima pergunta da jf
venda ilhas o que artistas
internacionais você gosta e por que o
deixa o internacional algoz do galo e
verão lado ceará racional não vou falar
a verdade e atinge também o
internacional gosto johnny depp e eu
adoro o capitão daquele cara qualquer
filme que tiver deu eu gosto muito
obrigado e mexer ele falou pra falar a
verdade o artista medo
obrigada eu espécie é de gaza piora do
seu novo espetáculo aéreo em qualquer
instância a banda é presenciar um
milagre do dia de hoje quando duas
pessoas se gostam não fala a verdade e
pessoas digam que é fácil negociar não
ficar divulgando futuro
dez meses de namoro ele chama de verdade
pessoas que se amam de verdade esse ano
voltei no mato no inverno um batuque
logo qualquer lugar não fica legal do
facebook em financiar não é só a rocha é
isso aí
próxima pergunta e wilson é do ítalo
rodrigues é isso aí você se vê daqui a
cinco anos trabalhando ainda com um novo
trabalho na ilha como cria cara é o
seguinte
daqui a cinco anos eu pretendo trabalhar
com isso na minha cabeça já tocou na
minha cabeça eu quero trabalhar e eu
quero trabalhar com aqueles que eu gosto
não quero fazer um trabalho que eu
chegar em casa ou no mundo uma bem o que
eu me sinto mal que é trabalho que eu
gosto e não sei que o youtube é que
cinco anos com quem mais um gol pra mim
tá bom próxima pergunta próxima pergunta
da florzinha sara bebe e rafa
sozinho o que fazer quando estamos
totalmente apaixonado na casa ela tá
mais apaixonada chega no cabo camargo
meio quero que casa
próxima pergunta é da b abre parênteses
city seja 42
como foi a experiência de estar no
esquenta pra falar a verdade foi show
porque ouvi as pessoas que eu vi na
televisão para ficar e não tomou essa
pessoa
donna você está sentado lá da pessoa
próxima pergunta estamos a fernandes
coloninha
você acha que quando a menina fica com o
menino que tem namorada era pra só se
iludindo
depende do ano é muito carente pô está
muito carente ou é [ __ ] opel namorada
nem sabe sabe não sabe então namorado na
beleza ou ela é da quebrada mesmo tá nem
aí pra por dia o que acontece na vida
ou ela está precisando de um namorado
gente pega o boné da portela ponto final
o idt é quando vai ter o vídeo teu e do
caio oliveira juntos eu não sei o que
espera não ver o carro e veio pra poder
fazer um vídeo com ele quebrou na foto
ele mora muito longe e e julgar pela
ligeira tem um recado ao catuaí
eu sei que você manda um recado ao
cantar meu irmão ricardo andré pior
ainda é o pior não pressionar pelo que a
laura do próxima pergunta da adri
branchini coroinha que dia você faz
aniversário e qual seria o presente
ideal eu faço aniversário no dia 5 de
janeiro de 2014 aí só depois me 15 não
faço mais no dia 16 o domingo 14 no
outono é todo ano no dia 5 de janeiro
terça
eu acho incrível aniversário cai sempre
o elogia da escola como a que eu acho
incrível no aniversário sempre a minha
virada do ano sempre caymmi mulher a
quem tem um desenho de como eu fique
entre um pro outro do dia 31 podiam sair
foi o natal no dia 24 de junho não é em
dois por dia entre 24 e fugas ao nosso
interior
evans seria o ideal repetir o encontro
de fãs aqui em recife que foi boa foi
massa de maio deu aqui sei lá eu acho
que é uma dessas pessoas
ae
o
ai ai ai ai
aí o i
ai ai ai
ae
ai ai
o time chegou a dez mas parece dormiu
gostar
estou aqui com esquenta acabou com ele e
falei que ficou famoso e ficou famoso
depois que ele conheceu o salão branco
ac boa só foi mesmo o tempo é melhor
parar na próxima pergunta é da mariana
as evento para escolher quem devia fazer
senão como é que a próxima pergunta da
maia raser medo é verdade que os homens
mesmo preferem menina sem maquiagem
carlo que estilo de toque beijos adoro
você busca de ouro
na verdade a gente gosta da mulher do
ditador ao que ela é porq porque é
maquiada ela é bonita e tal aí no outro
dia quando quer acordar é a máscara dela
[Música]
i e ii
i
ae o flamengo a mulher maquiada é bonito
mas você venezuela sem maquiagem aí você
sabe se ela é realmente bonita e se como
a que haja mais bonita do que ela é e
não só colocando a casa que eu tinha uma
idéia é ter uma experiência dessa nem
conhecer pessoas bonitas internet como
exemplo pessoal e sim mas cheguei cheio
mas tem aquela mulher que usa maquiagem
de volta o negócio em bush aqui vêm
mesmo quem mais levou dois tapas que
assim é
[Música]
flávia melo pergunta que time sai daqui
90 e vai mobilizar de novo aí basta
perguntar mas a pergunta óbvia melo
pergunta quais cantores ou bandas mais
alvim e ultimamente eu estou escutando
leandro léo e cantar aquela música joão
de barro eu acho muito bonita
eu topo também a dupla certo nem
quiseram agora quer gabriel de oliveira
é o que gostamos mas uma pergunta o
gabrielli câmara porque as meninas estão
ficando sem atitude beijos favor de 2002
grande atitude
culpa do facebook antigamente era passar
mel nem vai apostar em que ela estava
empurrando o outro português é chegar a
pé
e aí primeira pergunta que fazem é
assunto quente mas é verdade ou não e eu
quero chegar a este poder é como a
costumeira o cara chegava na menina e
conversava com ela e comandava o papa e
na casa da menina após namorar na volta
ou saía pra algum lugar onde não cara
chega no facebook aí gata quer transar
na beleza bota aí e vai pô
então ficava tocando do cabo de rede
social vai hoje uma última pergunta se
ele os foguetes iranianos dos bichos
porque você não grava um vídeo todo dia
e adorar manda um beijo pra mim
téo e no final do dia que cantava e tem
como davam me decidi durante anos joga
no youtube não tem como
mas se eu pudesse também é assim
vou tentar algum dia na minha vida
é pra você participar há como livros
como esse poder fazer sua pergunta é só
você me seguir no twitter ao gol inglês
tom míssel instagram aqui também e ele
assina no facebook e é isso aí galera
muito obrigado a adquirir esse vídeo
estamos aqui com um cara livre do canal
já fundaria e daí
aqui na tela é o link do canadá que a
descrição do vídeo estamos aqui também
com gabi a viver no canal 10
quer dizer que é um prazer em estar aqui
fala gravada com eles ou muita gente
pediu ainda mais junto né
estamos simplesmente não gosto do jeito
que a gente queria transando com foto já
falei várias vezes isso por telefone
você facebook pode começar a educar é
[ __ ]
melhor só 10 da galera canal porto velho
está embaixo isso mostrou a fazer todo
mundo aqui é muito [ __ ] tudo é resultado
de todo nordeste todo sempre encontrando
é também temos que dar valor que nossa
querida num e e ele é nosso rei
fui e de cada criança ele é o cara da
posição que também o joão pedro e também
um erro aqui e tá que tá aqui mas sei
muito obrigado você tem assistido se
você gostou desse vídeo fica quem gostei
de ajuda para [ __ ]
e é isso aí se você não tá escrito
nacional clique aqui e inscrever-se e
tocando em bandas já falou meu irmão
[Música]